duane dog chapman you know he already is
a new york times best-selling author and
now
dog is adding another accomplishment to
his resume
you become a movie star how how'd i do
for being myself
come on he won the only
dog the bounty hunter what was that like
for you
playing in a movie where the husband
loses his wife
if you've been through the scenes
actually in your life
you're just bringing it back up i didn't
have to pretend
i just let it out right love her kiss
her
hug her whatever she wants it's been
just over a year since dog lost his wife
and reality tv companion beth
to cancer who's your favorite man in the
world
tomorrow the 67 year old channels that
pain into his new faith-based film
hunter's creed his character helps
another man cope
with the death of his wife
they say here's the script you can
improvise if you'd like right so
i knew robin williams improvised all the
time
so i do it right and i'm like whoa that
was great and they go dog could you kind
of
stick to the script you're like oh no
if i don't find them i'm gonna find out
what happened
i got really got into it good lord it is
hard
no you stay up studying your lines and
it's it's incredible in real life dog
has found love
after loss during our exclusive sit-down
interview
he introduced me to his new fiance well
kevin meet francie so nice to meet you
francie lost her spouse to cancer just
six months
before beth passed away tell me about
the engagement
well you know it's not my first rodeo no
i got down on one knee and said francie
frank will you marry me
and i said can i i'm saying it so i say
help me back up
and she's like standing there i was
crying and nervous
and you did she didn't even pull me back
up i had to limp up
he did a great job and it was really
romantic
you